Vous savez maintenant
Noël et moi, c'est une longue histoire
C'est pour moi ?
Non, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est quoi, c'est quoi ?
C'est un cadeau ?
C'est une surprise ?
C'est ça ! Qu'est ce que c'est ?
C... C'était un hamster.
À chaque fois qu'on s'approche des fêtes
Je pense à Noël quand j'étais gamin
Parce que j'étais euphorique
J'étais comme un dingue
Quelques semaines avant Noël
Pour moi c'était impossible
De ne pas chercher les cadeaux partout dans la maison
Alors je sais, c'est débile
Je me spoilais tout, comme un con
Et le pire, c'est que je devais jouer la surprise
Quand je déballais mes cadeaux, du coup
WAOUH
Des rollers !
Merci Maman !
C'est le cadeau de Mamie, que t'es en train d'ouvrir, là
Ah oui !
Ça veut dire que j'ai deviné ton cadeau ?
J'ai des super-pouvoirs !
En parlant de cadeaux
Quand j'étais gamin, je pouvais clairement identifier deux types de Noël bien distinct
D'abord le Noël où je recevais une console
Et puis, il y avait les autres Noël ...
Ah !
Des crayons de couleurs !
Histoire vraie
Merci papa, merci maman
Alors je vais pas me plaindre
C'est bien des crayons de couleurs
Il y a des enfants dans le monde qui ont moins bien que ça pour Noël
Donc je me plains pas
Par contre
Je dirai pas mon cadeau à mes potes, à l'école
Moi j'ai eu une voiture téléguidée, qui se transforme quand elle roule, un truc sympa, et toi ?
J'ai eu des crayons de couleurs
Quoi ?
Laser !
Des crayons de couleurs laser qui envoient des trucs sur les murs et tout
Ah tu m'as fait  peur, d'accord !
Tu les ramènes ?
NON
C'est MON cadeau
Alors je sais pas comment ça se passe dans les autres familles
Mais moi mes parents, ils sont plutôt nuls en Noël
On ouvrait les cadeaux le soir, et mes parents avaient une technique carrément cheloue
Pour mettre les cadeaux au pied du sapin sans qu'on le voit
Ils me demandaient :
Cyprien, vas ranger ta chambre
Oui
Histoire vraie
Le soir de Noël
Grosse, grosse ambiance
Bah, du coup, je rangeais ma chambre, et quand je revenais :
Oh, t'as loupé le père Noël, il a déposé les cadeaux !
Bon, le problème avec cette technique
En plus d'être totalement nulle à chier
C'est que ça marche qu'une fois
"Cyprien, vas ranger ta cham-"
J'ai déjà rangé ma chambre !
Est-ce que t'as passé ...
J'ai passé l'aspirateur, j'ai replié mes vêtements, j'ai resserré le lit, j'ai refais la peinture, l'électricité, le chauffage au sol, l'isolation, j'ai coulé une dalle et j'ai pété un mur pour aggrandir
Ah bah mince, pendant que tu parlais le père Noël a déposé les cadeaux !
Merde !
Je me rappelle très bien du moment où j'ai arrêté de croire au père Noël
C'était justement un soir de Noël
C'était mon oncle qui s'était déguisé en père Noël
Alors il était plutôt bien déguisé, là n'est pas le problème
Le problème, c'est qu'il est resté déguisé toute la soirée
Hé, Cyprien, tu me passes la bouteille ?
Histoire vraie
La bouteille
Sinon, ça va l'école ?
Il est pas un peu con, ton fils ?
Et d'ailleurs le Noël dernier j'ai pu me déguiser en père Noël
C'est pas une blague
C'était mon voisin qui m'avait demandé de me déguiser pour ses enfants
Comme ils ne m'avaient jamais vus, du coup ils étaient obligés de croire que le père Noël existait
Enzo, voilà le père Noël
Oh, c'est encore tonton déguisé en père No-
Bon, j'y ai peut-être pris un peu trop goût
Et ouais, tu pensais que c'était ton oncle ?
Et je suis qui ?
Le père Noël ?
Plus jamais tu crois plus en moi, t'entends ?
Oui !
Oui, qui ?
Oui le père Noël
Oui, le père Noël et bah voilà, c'est pas si dur !
Tu vas faire quoi, qu'est-ce-que tu vas faire ?
Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire face au père Noël ?
Je peux voler dans un traîneau
Mes amis ce sont des putains de lutins !
Père Noël !
Si je veux des cadeaux ?
Père Noël, père Noël !
Zéro, mon gars !
Cyprien, OH!
C'est le prénom du voisin, ça
Et y a un truc qui me manque, un truc qui n'existe plus, un truc, quand je le voyais, je savais que c'était bientôt Noël
C'était cette pub :
*C'est moi, le père Noël, tous les enfants peuvent me téléphoner, écoutez bien mon numéro :
08 36 65 65 65
Si un enfant veut arrêter de croire au père Noël de manière immédiate
Faut qu'il appelle ce numéro
Parce que le service existe encore, hein ! Et c'est la plus grosse arnaque de la planète !
J'espère que tu as bien été sage pendant toute cette année, dis moi, tu n'as pas fait trop de bêtises au moins ?
J'ai tué quelqu'un
Aaaah, bon ! Et, au fait, comment t'appelles-tu ?
Adolf Hitler
Et où habites-tu ?
Dans ton cul, connard !
Aaaaah !
Bon, j'avoue préférer Noël quand j'étais plus jeune
Avant, Noël c'était ...
DES CADEAUX, DES CADEAUX !
Bon et maintenant c'est plus :
DE LA BOUFFE, DE LA BOUFFE
Et encore
Parce que le soir de Noël, sur la table de mes parents, il y a toujours deux trucs, qui sont toujours là
Le foie gras
Ça, ça va, jusqu'à ce que ma soeur intervienne
T'as vu cette vidéo sur le gavage des canards ?
*Le canard cherche à fuir et tente désespérément d'échapper au gavage*
(Bruits de gorge)
Et mon père raffole des huîtres !
Et il y en a tous les ans !
Ça, je ne peux pas. Je suis désolé. Dans ma tête les huitres sont faites comme ça
*Usine à huître*
(Bruit de reniflement et de glaire)
Elle est bien jaune.
Merci
Suivante !
Oui
(Bruit de glaire)
Et comme c'est bientôt Noël, et que vous avez été sages
J'ai un petit cadeau !
J'ai créé pour vous le site "JMEFAISCHIER.FR"
C'est pour quand vous vous faîtes chier, vous indiquez le temps que vous avez à perdre sur le site
Et ça vous crée une playlist aléatoire de mes vidéos
Et surtout à la fin des vidéos vous aurez
droit à des anecdotes inédites, comme par exemple des bêtisiers
Ou des scènes coupées
Allez-y, c'est mon cadeau de Noël !
JME, pas JE ME. Parce qu'en fait je ne sais pas écrire, en vrai
Tcho !
Sous-titrage : Faustin Héline